NARRATOR: Bull sharks bite with
more force, pound for pound,
than any other species
of large shark.
But in Texas waters,
they don't frequently
turn their teeth on humans.
That is, until 2010--
three attacks in
less than a year.
The safety and livelihood
of local residents
is under threat.
Galveston is a tourism mecca,
but having a bunch of shark
attacks in a short span
makes people question
whether to go the beach.
NARRATOR: All three attacks
take place in the waters off
of Galveston Island, so wildlife
journalist Chester Moore
returns to the scene to
search for clues that
may shed light on the mystery.
And near the water's edge,
he spies something striking.
CHESTER MOORE: This
is an incredible plant
called Sargassum.
NARRATOR: Sargassum
is a floating seaweed.
Much of it originates
in the Sargasso Sea,
a vast 3,000-mile long stretch
of ocean in the North Atlantic.
But closer to home, Chester
has noticed something sinister.
This seaweed seems
to attract sharks.
When I'm out there fishing
and I see a bunch of Sargassum,
I know I'm probably
going to catch sharks.
NARRATOR: What is it
about this tiny plant that
appeals to sharks,
and how could it
explain the spike in attacks?
Biologist Larry
McKinney has been
studying the Texas coastline
for more than 40 years.
He says the answer
may come down to what
lies hidden within Sargassum.
This is a mobile habitat.
NARRATOR: The seaweed
provides food,
refuge, and breeding grounds
for an array of critters.
The types of animals that
are associated with Sargassum
are particularly small, starting
with small crabs and shrimp.
NARRATOR: These
animals, in turn,
attract a variety
of larger species
like fish and sea turtles,
the preferred prey of sharks.
LARRY MCKINNEY: Any
place that would
concentrate a food source,
sharks will always come.
NARRATOR: Normally, Sargassum
floats to the Texas shore
in small bits and pieces.
LARRY MCKINNEY: Today, we
have kind of a normal amount
of Sargassum.
NARRATOR: But around the time of
the attacks, something changed.
What I'm looking
at here are satellite
photographs of the coast
of Texas during 2010, 2011.
If you look just off shore, now
each one of these green dots,
these are big
patches of Sargassum.
They were coming in
in mats that were
the size of a football field.
You can actually see
Sargassum from space.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: In
Galveston, the seaweed
buries the beach in huge heaps.
Experts believe this
sudden influx of Sargassum
may be the result of a variety
of environmental factors
including strong winds
and a steady rise
in ocean temperatures.
And the seaweed invasion
isn't limited to Texas.
Beaches in Florida,
the Caribbean,
West Africa, and South
America are also inundated.
LARRY MCKINNEY: No
matter what they tried
to do to clean it up,
within a few days,
more were coming ashore.
NARRATOR: It's a
worldwide Sargassum siege.
[music playing]
Could sharks be following this
seaweed snack into the Texas
shallows, thereby increasing
the risk of an accidental run-in
with humans?
According to McKinney,
sharks do follow
the mats, but only so far.
Well, you see, most of the
fish feeding on Sargassum
is out past these breakers.
Once it gets up
into these sandbars,
it starts rolling over and over.
The small animals do drop
out and they disperse.
NARRATOR: So once
the seaweed reaches
the shallows where humans
are, it loses its appeal.
So the idea that Sargassum
attracted sharks into this area
is probably not very likely.